hello and welcome to the 23rd PHP
tutorial in this Victoria we're going to
be covering and a little bit more depth
string manipulation so with that let's
hop right on into it streaming the
emulation is pretty useful for a whole
lot of different applications and the
first thing I really would like to show
you is a scenario where you do want to
use double quotes versus single quotes
where it really will matter and make
your life a little bit easier and really
your code easier to reach at the end of
the day that that matters a lot as well
so sometimes it's a toss up but let's
just make an example string and we're
just to say hey there buddy is our
sample string what you can do is if you
let's just echo out something if you
echo out in single quotes string and
then how are you right if you do this
it's literally gonna echo out dollar
sign string how are you in fact let's go
ahead and put that up just to show you
what's happening there so we're refresh
and it literally says string how are you
but what happens if we in case of some
double quotes as you can see it's
already you've begun to bold dollar sign
string so when we save this and refresh
now it actually says hey there buddy how
are you and it's starting to act a
little bit like we would expect it to
act normally without using the full stop
that we had done before so I mean you
can also do the full stop where it's
like this put that up and you get
exactly the exact same string but when
you're like zooming through code and
stuff and you're like maybe you're
looking for you know the specific string
sometimes it can be easier to both code
it and read you know what's exact
happening by doing it this way so next
up what we want to do is we'll leave the
string here but I'm going to show you
guys you know something that people
typically are going to want to do is
split up strings by a specific string
there's other ways you can split up
strings by like word and all this kind
of stuff but you can also just learn one
way to split up strings and use it on
every application you know that you
might want to use it for so doing this
is actually really simple
with a while loop and then also you'll
just need to specify the token so to do
that lets just call literally a variable
token say token is equal to and the way
you call this it's strt okay string
token and then within here you want to
the first parameter is what you want to
apply this to so in this case we want to
do this to string and then the second
case is what do you want the token to be
and a good way to think of it is if you
ever if you're from coming from Python
or another language it's really what
you're going to split by so let's say
you want to tokenize by the space so
we'll just tokenize by a space and
that's it so now if all we do is just
print out tokens so let's just echo
token save that and come over well we
get it so far is just hey we don't get
the full like everything split we just
only get the first one so naturally we
need a while loop mm-hmm and we're going
to just loop through this so we're gonna
say Wow token doesn't equal false now
what token is going to we can return is
a false so if there's nothing left for
it
tokenized then it will return a false
Buie so what's happening is what it's
doing is it's like it's tokenizing by
this a single time so what you want to
do is just say while it doesn't equal
false so you can make it dynamic here
now we want to add what we want to do so
let's go ahead and echo let's echo that
actual token as you can see we're going
to put this within double quotes so it
acts as a variable and then we're going
to go ahead and break double quote and
then we're going to want to rename the
token so we're gonna do token each
little string token and then space space
so what this will do is loop through and
for every well in our case it's gonna be
every word since we're gonna split by
this space and then it's gonna it's
going to echo out the word split by
space echo out the word split by space
so let's go ahead and run this hopefully
we don't have any typos and sure enough
we get hey there buddy so that's just a
way you could split by space but you of
course you could split by anything else
you wanted you could split by e for
example so let's change this to a letter
e and change this to a letter E save it
come over here refresh and now you've
got there buddy
so anyway what you're gonna split by
ends up being lost much like in Python
when you do a split by a string variable
so this is a good way to split by any
method you might want now there's a
couple other things that we're going to
run through real quick with string
manipulation and that's going to be
string length one of the things that you
might want to do like say you have like
a comment box and you want to limit you
know how many comment or how many like
lines of textual store or something like
that it could be useful to know how many
characters or even how many words are in
there so the next thing you might want
to do is utilize string length and
that's just STR lens so let's show you
that what
call this string Len I would need all
the Sun equals STR Len and then in
parenthesis you just say what you want
to know what the string length is oh so
in this case we want to know it for
string just our string variable and then
let's go ahead and echo out string what
will save that pop over here and as you
see it's 15 so it's literally 15
characters so those are just a few
different ways you can work with strings
as always thank you for watching and
stay tuned the next video we'll be
talking about even more ways and things
that we can do with strings